marketing your Biz and your Vlogs the
power of mentioning y'all you ain't got
to oversell you can mention things and
sometimes if I just mention my course
and I just talk about some of the slides
that I'm working on and some of the
things that I'm doing in it I see an
increase in sales also entertaining and
educative I find that that is like the
perfect mix of being able to actually
sell when you are vlogging you're
getting them emotionally invested but
when you educate you're getting them
mentally invested blogging kind of
morphs the two things which makes it the
perfect place for upselling make sure
that you include some entertainment
education add some music spice it up
like make it something that you would
watch